hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan today I'm
answering a question from one of my
readers Leo who's a YouTube viewer love
you YouTube guys thank you for writing
his question is about someone yourself
so I wrote in hi your videos are so
helpful especially for those who are new
when it comes to business when you can
you make a video on how to approach
people like how you make them excited
about your business or recruit them
thank you so much again so thanks for
the question Leo I'm gonna break that
into two two components so I just lost
it
there we go the fingers are little
fidgety here so I'm gonna break it into
two components first is going up and
approaching people and how to get people
to know about your business and a second
is how to get them excited about it the
first in terms of going up and
approaching people I think it depends on
your personality me personally I
consider myself more of a marker than
the salesperson if I go up at a
networking event or business event I'm
usually not in everybody's face saying
hi here's what I do you got to come sign
up with me and go check out my website
I'm generally a little more introverted
a little more shy I guess I'm I like
talking to people but I'm not a heavy
promoter not a heavy salesperson I guess
and so the strategy that I've used is
more of a pull strategy so instead of
going out and trying to recruit people
and talk to people I try to have people
come and find me and I find that I'm a
lot better at being able to can to get
people interested in what I'm doing once
they are coming to me and so I think a
lot of entrepreneur outgoing and you
know loved going out and just promoting
themselves and handing out business
cards so how I do things is so you know
I didn't have a great time sales the
doing sales calls or cold calling people
or I never went door-to-door or anything
like that but I wouldn't be really good
at that so how I do things is I try to
create content that is interesting for
my target audience and I'll market it so
I had the website I had
my YouTube videos I have Twitter and
LinkedIn and Facebook and all those
channels to help market my material so
it starts with creating interesting
things that your target audience would
be interested in and showcasing yourself
as an expert and if you're not your
printer you should be an expert at what
you're doing right whatever clock the
service is trying to sell you should
have a story that you can tell and you
should be one of the best in the world
at what you do and combining your
various passions into one business it's
a great way to be able to do it because
that's uniquely you and something nobody
else can can copy or replicate so you
want to be pushing out that content and
marketing it and showing that it's value
out for your target audience and people
will hopefully find it you can create
partnerships to get that content out
there but that's the strategy I've
always used and so making videos like
this you're speaking at conferences like
I'll really go to an event unless I'm
speaking at it a lot of us do the time I
don't have a lot of time available to go
out do these things but when I go to an
event and I'm a speaker I find a lot of
people come up to me and ask me
questions I end up finding new business
opportunities or new connections where
if I'm an attendee I'm not the guy who's
going around shaking everybody's hand
and introducing myself and you know try
to make business happen again I try to
for my own personality I'm not that kind
of guy and so I tried to leverage my
strengths and not play to my weaknesses
and so I'll try to be the speaker and
get people to come to me so a lot of my
business is around getting people to
find me and marketing to them and then
once we start a discussion it's easy to
move forward from there so that's how I
get people interested in
I guess finding out about me the second
part was how to get them excited about
your business and I think the real thing
that comes through is your own
excitement you know I love
entrepreneurship I love helping
entrepreneurs when I'm sitting in front
of an entrepreneur there's an energy
that I get I want to help them out I
want to find a way to go their business
even talking about it now I'm getting
excited that's what I love doing and so
if you're excited about whatever
business you have that's going to come
through
other people will get excited and
although they'll catch your fever if
you're just going through your pitch and
you know some people come and I was
pitched recently with this guy had a
kind of like a PowerPoint but he had it
written down so instead of using the
computer he brought two binders and he
went through one and I went through one
it was it was just born because he's
just reading his slides that's not great
like that's not showing passion we'd be
great information great value maybe a
great ideas in there for me but I want
to see your passion and excitement and
it's not so much what you say it's how
you say it and if people genuinely sense
that you're excited about this
opportunity then they'll get more
excited as well so it really starts with
you having something that you are
genuinely excited about so when you're
starting the business you want to build
it around something you are passionate
about something that you can wake up and
get going every morning not maybe every
morning because I know it can be hard
but almost every morning you wake up
excited to go and do what you're doing
that passion will come through and other
people will want to join with you on
whatever you're passionate about if
you're just doing it to make money or
you just go through the motions and
you're not really excited if you don't
personally use your product or service
and you can't tell a personal story
about why you started it or while you're
involved in the business then it's gonna
be a lot harder to get people excited
about it even if you have the best case
studies in the world so hopefully that
helped maybe a little bit different
about how I approach it compared to
others but hopefully some information
there that can help you with your
business so thanks for the question
for those of you watching if you liked
it please give it a thumbs up I love
seeing them come in and if you have a
question about this video or question
about your own company or challenge that
you're facing feel free leave in the
comment section below I always read
those I love seeing them come in so
thank you and I'll see you on the next
episode